yes this is uh
the same talk i gave in san diego this
summer so if you like uh
do you know there's a it's a no waste
policy i'm recycling
and so
also i want to apologize because being a
local just right after that i have to
dash out for a meeting so
thank you for inviting me to this
workshop so i want to tell you a little
bit about
a very practical problem that i i've
been encountering in dealing with uh
practical uses of optimization which is
basically the idea that optimization
problems usually do not come in
isolation it's not as a single instance
but most often it's multiple instance
and
how can we exploit the available
structure if any to go faster and solve
these problems uh with multiple
instances
so
here's an example here's a
famous problem in statistics which is
basically least squares
and then there's a penalty for
sparsity so this is the famous lasso
problem in many cases you might want to
solve the same problem with the similar
response but different matrices
all these matrices are just
a rank one modification of the same
matrix
so
obtained by taking a big data matrix and
removing say one or a few columns
in resource management often we might
have
a
linear programming problem where this
vector might represent demand
and x is an allocation of resources
and c might represent the cost which
what we want to minimize
and the the network of the distribution
of the resource problem is always the
same
but the demand changes or the cost
changes or both
so
further
here is an example that's a more
elaborate example from statistics which
basically
takes a covariance matrix an empirical
covariance matrix typically and tries to
represent its inverse in a sparser form
so it's a specification of a graph here
x is the
estimate of the new covariance matrix
whose inverse is sparse you might wonder
why sparsity of the inverse has any
interest in statistics it just means
that the conditional dependent structure
of the graph is now sparse if x here
is false so
solving this problem is challenging for
large networks so
here
there is an approach and algorithm that
has been proposed which basically takes
every node and regresses it against the
other every node is a random variable
and you regress
in a sparse way
that's the lasso problem now here the
problem is that these matrices from
regressing one node against all
and then you go on to the next node the
matrix doesn't change much just a rank
one modification
so here is a more uh
recent application of the same kind of
problem where you have multiple
instances of similar problems
this is an approach where essentially
we're trying to estimate a sparse
distribution variable p
given
some knowledge about moments so you have
linear constraints on that distribution
and you want to minimize the cardinality
if you use l1 norm technique to solve
this problem where you you don't get
anywhere because the l1 norm is just one
so
it doesn't
allow you to
encourage sparsity and turn the crank
and get a sparser and sparser
distribution
so a new approach has been proposed
where basically you solve these problems
but
each problem from one instance to the
next has the only difference is the cost
changes and here you're maximizing one
particular index
of the variable and then you go on to
the next variable so these problems
share a lot of structure
okay so we can be all convinced that
there is a lot of applications
of uh problems where you have similar
instances that differ by just not much
here's another example
from
emmanuel candice and his co-authors
where you have to solve
some kind of sparse
estimation problem and again now you're
fixing some value a specific index to
zero
okay so uh
there's a lot of tasks like this where
the the problems have
a lot of similar structures
now what can we do uh
beyond multiple instance well if we just
have a multiple instance problem i don't
know but on in addition to this there's
structure for example
here is an example of a multiple
instance
but here the
all we're doing is varying the parameter
of the penalty
it turns out that in many
classes of practical applications this
matrix has low rank
or some simple structure or close to low
rank so how can we exploit these two the
multiple instance aspect and the low
rank aspect that's the focus now why do
i see that many problems have a low rank
structure
the problem that i'm outlining here
actually comes up in text analytics for
example when you're trying to classify
documents and these are renditions of
illustrations essentially of the fact
that the data that comes from these text
classification problems has a lot of low
rank so these are very large matrices
they're very sparse but still their rank
is close to being small
so
these two graphs
ex
explain that show that
so
in robust sketching
the basic idea is you want to replace a
problem which involves here convex
typically a loss function
here is a linear operator containing the
data
you want to replace it by a low rank
matrix why because then you can go
faster at solving the problem
if you just do brutally that replacement
then it's not
doing necessarily what we want because
that procedure makes introduce noise
and so the robust sketching idea is to
go beyond sketching which is compressing
the data into a simple structure
but to take into account the error made
induced by the sketching so here the
this is the paradigm that i'm proposing
where we start with this problem
and a is low rank
then what we do here is
address
here a proxy for this
where
a is replaced by b
a is replaced by a tilde which is low
rank
and
in effect this bound
is
reflective of the fact that a tilde is
just an approximation of a
and therefore a is within that set a is
one of the b's
and therefore this takes into account
the error made by replacing a with a
tilde so this is a bound on this problem
and it induces a way to
exploit the fact that
a is close to low rank but not
forgetting that we have made an error
in that matrix so um
the short story is that there's multiple
ways to apply this
paradigm and in what we have served we
can show that
we can dramatically reduce computational
time
in addition when you're doing
optimization problems we can guarantee
the feasibility of the
approximate solution
okay so i
i'll focus first on sparse learning
application where basically these are
often without constraints or the
constraints don't have data in them and
it's an easy case
the harder case
is when you have a resource management
problem for example when you have
constraints you have to satisfy them so
just brutally replacing
the data in your lp by another
will not just generate a feasible
solution for the original problem
so
here again is a text analytics example
i'm not going to comment on that graph
just to be saying that
in text
classification for example there's a lot
of need for solving very large
statistical problem with low rank and
with
multiple instance
so the idea is this imagine that
we want to solve some kind of sparse
classification problem
x is a very large close to low rank
matrix
and we need to solve this problem
in multiple instances that is maybe we
have different y's okay many different
ways to solve or many different lambdas
so it makes sense to spend some time
to prepare the the problem and
approximate this guy with a low rank
that is has a cost but it's like a
pre-loaded cost
and once that approximation is ready we
implement a robust sketching idea for
each instance
so in this idea of topic imagine which i
won't comment much it's basically about
understanding how a certain topic is
treated in a
large set of documents
then
x here
is
a rank one modification
of the whole data it's the whole data
minus
one row basically
and um
the whole data set
uh which i call extilt here is very
close to low rank
and y is essentially extracted from that
one row that you you remove and uh
basically that's the problem when we end
up with
so what we do here is we say well let's
replace x by its low rank approximation
and then take into account the error
made
epsilon here is the estimate on the
error made
so that
estimate
basically computing this low rank
approximation and that number
is done before any
application so we just take the whole
data set we do that
and then we solve this problem each time
we have a specific instance to solve
this results in this case in a very
simple modification where you have a
term here that involves the l2 norm this
is an elastic net as it's called in the
in the field now this problem has a lot
of structure because this is low rank
you can readily see why it's possible to
solve it much faster than the original
problem if the rank is low why because
evaluating sub gradients of this
function here
is very fast in fact this matrix vector
multiply
it goes linearly with the
uh
with the the size of the problem
with k fixed so yes
going from one line to the next is that
heuristic or are you saying there's a ah
thank you no it's not it's an exact uh
you can so this is not hard to show that
this
thing is exactly that yes it's a good
point
um so here is just a little remark
to say
statistically this approach
simply entails brutally replacing the
data matrix by its low rank
approximation remember before we had x
here the original data
and then adding a little term that takes
into account the error so it could be a
heuristic in fact it's it's a natural
thing to do
if without the theory right
what this
epsilon does this elastic net term does
is allow you a much better control on
sparsity what happens is this if you
didn't have this term
and k was the rank of this matrix you
can show that just solving for those
first two terms this is due to my
student vu farm
a recent result shows that in fact you
cannot your solution will be
at most case zeros
so meaning you don't control the
sparsity
so here is an illustration for the case
when the data is rank one
this is the case when we don't take into
account this error and we try to
improve the sparsity or control the
sparsity with this number here
as lambda grows there's more and more
sparse
but in fact what happens is that all the
components are zero except one and then
it dies out so basically the sparsity is
just one you do there's no control
whereas here with the other term you
control better you're allowed to choose
that sparsity
it's just a side remark i'm just not
saying this as a central piece but just
to say that brutally replacing in those
statistical problems
the data by its low rank approximation
has a benefit it brings you
speed but you lose something
statistically now the main result is
that this problem also can be solved
very fast
so in fact you can analyze a little more
and you can decompose this problem into
two problems one involving one dimension
the row dimension and the other the
column dimension so you solve two
problems separately and each one is much
sparser to solve than the original
problem they look like lasso type
problems and i won't go into the details
so the net result is that you gain one
order of magnitude if n is the number of
variables in this problem this number of
variables in w which is typically very
large for example in text analytics what
w is is the number of terms that ever
appear in your whole corpus so it could
be a hundred thousand a million
if you take
multiple terms and so this is usually a
problem where the number of variables is
very big
and in in effect this whole thing
says that if you
have here a rank k matrix then the
complexity goes down by
one order of magnitude
now again i want to emphasize the
multi-instance requirement
you can always do this
on a single instance
but it really makes sense and is
beneficial when you have many instances
because the work of forming the low rank
approximation is then just a one-time
thing you do and then all the other
instances of the problem will involve
either the same low rank approximation
or just a rank one modification
of it
so here's the gain in a computational
time where we look at the ratio between
solving the original problem
and solving a robust low rank version so
basically um
essentially what this graph tries to
show is a theoretical bound versus uh
you know on synthetic data uh an
experimental bound and what it shows
here is that there is an order of
magnitude increa uh
benefit to this whole thing all right so
this is just from one instance
so if you have multiple instances this
is also uh even better
because the work you do spending
on getting the low rank approximation is
done once and for all
question yes i don't understand the term
sketching what's inside the schedule oh
yes this is a computer science uh
originally a term
that essentially
you know sketching we know what
sketching is just making a drawing that
summarizes a little bit the the scene
and doesn't fill in all the details and
so the original idea was in databases
they would for example do sub sampling
that's an a particular kind of sketching
where you reduce
your whole data
into a simpler form that is supposed to
be some kind of sketch
and
the low rank sketching is a particular
instance of that where you approximate
the matrix by its low rank approximation
oh okay it's just approximation
okay yes that sketch okay
so um we did some experiments did that
purple to show
that not only you gain computationally
but you don't lose on the quality of the
results
so i'm gonna be
very uh quick because you might not be
interested in machine learning and so on
maybe you are i don't know
yes
supposedly this would work too with
specification instead of taking the
right yes i'm mentioning this at the end
yes
but i've not done that
because i have yet
so this is an appeal to the audience if
you have a data that is dense
and that's huge you i i mean i have not
found a problem i think in mri they have
stuff like that but it's it's kind of
hard to find an example where you have a
huge data set a very dense matrix
and then you want to sparsify you know
and the
obvious problem is trackable in the same
way we tell infinity yes l infinity norm
will appear
yes
that's a very good point
so what these experiments show uh you
can focus on one of these curves
corresponding to two data sets
basically
we're trying to approximate the data and
the data you know it's it's not as
simple or
it's kind of large scale
basically we have 20 000 documents uh
and 40 000 so 20 000 uh
columns and 40 000 rows
it's not trivial
and here we have 28 000 columns and 49
000 rows so it's it's
you know it's a big matrix
and we approximate it by rank
5 10 to 50. so it's a very low rank
approximation and very fast to compute
with power iteration you know
and here what it shows is that at rank
10 or so
we recover the same
statistical performance
you know remember this is a sparse
classification task so in other words
that there is a statistical performance
associated with solving the optimization
problem we just it's not just we want to
solve the problem there is an end task
and this graphs
measure some kind of statistical
performance level and so this red guy
here this dot is what you do if you
don't do any
compressing robust catching nothing you
just solve the problem
and uh we recover the same performance
at rank
11 approximation
okay or so
so um
actually i'm sorry it's not rank 11.
what i'm trying to say is that about
rank 50 will recover
the same
performance
with a um
here is the the training time so
uh in other words uh
we we can go much faster but
we also benefit from the
from the
the fact that we reduce the rank of the
matrix
in a robust way
allows us to deal with the noise present
in the matrix
so
these results here are just yet another
application where we're now trying to
extract words that are predictive of a
certain theme
and for example
in a pubmed
data we're trying to extract words
related to cancer
and those are the words given
using these methods and just to say that
using here a
low rank approximation for a very large
matrix
20 is the rank we use so it's of
extremely low rank and still we get good
uh
words in words that are
uh makes sense okay
all right
so now i'm going to close the topic on
application of this robust sketching in
statistics this is the easy part because
we have no constraint
now
how about when you need to solve a large
linear programming problem and it turns
out that a has
close to some structure like low rank
if you just replace a by its low rank
approximation then this approach
miserably fails in statistics it doesn't
because you're just dealing with the
objective
function in which you replace data in
the objective so objective degrades and
so on but here
feasibility is impacted in the sense
that if you brutally replace this by a
low rank approximation and solve the
problem in most cases it might i mean it
might not be feasible and even if it is
then you end up with an x that's not
feasible for this problem that you
started with so your solution you're
generating that way
is nice but it's not feasible
but yes
so
the low rank helps you because you're
actually doing a matrix inversion in the
in the other optimization process okay
good question yeah you're asking whether
how to exploit the lowering structure
so either
yeah
it's a very
key point because either
you view this as a huh if you use like a
power method
you're not are you doing an excellent
version here no not an inversion but
imagine just computing the sub gradients
of this operator it involves
matrix vector multiplies with low rank
matrices so that's the high level reason
but
that approach
really asks you to use a specific
algorithm go inside the algorithm and
and change that thing
or you can analyze this and using
duality you can reduce the problem in a
very explicit way
so then this is algorithm independent
here
in other words you can exploit the low
rank either
at a very high level by looking
algorithmically what
you know you go inside the algorithm or
if you want to go outside the algorithm
you can still reduce the complexity
explicitly
i prefer this method because it's
algorithm independent
if you say like the the rank is 50
what if the matrix was sparse that you
know only have 50 50 non-zeros
would it be better to use the low rank
thing or the sparsity structure
the text i don't have a theoretical
answer to your question but in the text
applications typically matrices are very
sparse because most documents don't
contain both the words
so they're extremely sparse and yet a
very low rank structure but obviously
what
it's much faster yes
also you could do sparse low rank that's
another thing
so
i think i need to wrap up
but
essentially i'm gonna sketch
what i'm
trying to say now you get the idea is
instead of replacing
a in an lp by its lower end counterpart
you do take into account the error and
what in
entails is you apply this robust
idea where you
essentially
say that
for some delta
this expression is nothing else but a so
a is one of these examples
but
essentially it's as if you would say
i'm going to make sure that
for any matrix around the low rank
approximation in within a ball
my solution is feasible
and it turns out that a is within that
ball so
you know that
x you generate this way will be feasible
for that way
and this problem here is a very simple
conic programming problem so you might
wonder why why i'm in this
workshop it's because
due to the low rank spectral nature of
these approximation you end up with a
second order cone type of problem which
again you can exploit the low rank
structure in an explicit way or an
implicit way you can simply say well any
lp algorithm
would
require you to form this matrix vector
multiply and so it's understandable that
we can gain a lot
so i don't have any examples for that
last thing it's in the works
and um
yeah
so so you said before that in the lp
case alone forget about the robust part
yeah then
somehow you
that didn't work very well so why this
will
what yeah the
the thing is yeah all i'm saying is that
if you just repla in statistics for
example you can just say
here's the data i
compress it to a low rank and i run with
it i forget that it was you can do that
i said i argue that it's statistically
not the best idea but it's okay
here it's catastrophic
because
if you brutally replace a by low rank
then
you don't guarantee feasibility for the
original problem that was your problem
and so i think that's why the low rank
approximation idea which is so prevalent
in many fields has not been applied to
optimization yet that i have not seen
that
except when there is for example a qp
and a matrix
a quadratic matrix that is low rank or
factor model that has been applied but
not in the feasibility case because it
just doesn't solve your problem even
suboptimally this solves the problem
suboptimally
now the question is how much
suboptimality do we lose and i don't
know so there's a number of themes among
which is this idea of low rank is just
one a way to approximate so here for
example in the examples you just
discussed the matrix says you know more
than just the fact that you have a low
rank approximation of your matrix you
know that the matrix you're
approximating is actually sparse so you
could potentially include that
constraint as well in the the robust
version
to narrow down the set over which you're
making your problem that's a good point
i didn't think about it that means what
do you think
it depends uh bertsimas as a way to
handle
robustness with constraints where you
say how many
uh
the perturbation has limited cardinality
right so i think that could that's a
very interesting
so in the among the further topics is
what to do with sparse matrices and
in networks uh what is the good
approximation maybe low rank is not the
best thing to approximate a network and
so
okay so this is in the works and i don't
even have a draft to
so
you mentioned but this is
we have a lot of time somehow there was
a mismatch between the time and you have
a whole hour
but
uh yeah
um do you know anything about a matrix
lasso uh version of this
uh so are you talking about the case
when the the response vector is of is a
matrix
of course you would like it to be low
rank rather than sparse yeah ah okay so
in the
when the variable
yes it's it's uh it's very actually very
direct thing
uh in the sense that uh you you know um
basically what you're talking about is
something like that
something like that but this term this w
might be a matrix this y is a matrix and
this is a different norm uh then what
you do here is you add the same term
now what i don't know so then that's
that's just the probabilities norm on
the matrix now
uh this guy yes
let me think a little bit
no no it's a spectral norm
so it's a this would be the nuclear norm
this would be the spectral norm
but i don't know if then you can prove
this
like if you can go through here or just
algorithmically you have to look at
those problems and under the hood see
where you have matrix vector multiplies
so in this reformulation
somehow
when you write the one in the bottom
right you write s as a minimum of these
and somehow s and c they appear in right
you actually need to write it i mean
somehow in there
i can replace s by any optimal solution
somehow i
i'm solving those two things
simultaneously right
or in parallel yeah they're independent
uh this variable is independent from w
so you first solve a least squares
problem
and
basically the notation is just for for
one of the five terms yeah one column
yeah
and then the solution i plug it in right
so this has only um you know k variables
it's a very
uh skewed problem very fast and this is
also a very skewed problem but the under
other direction
so i'm not sure how to get this
decomposition
for all the
similar problems but for the lp case
there is one
for the qp there is one and for this one
there is one so it's so this is all for
general context
that's all right this does not hold for
the general context okay so for general
convex problems uh i'm not sure they
have but
essentially yeah
yeah yeah thank you thank you so for a
general let's say for this problem which
covers pretty much
a lot of things
uh f being convex
uh so there's uh
essentially uh if you
go and
look at this guy
so a low rank is the low rank
approximation this guy
is only tractable for some f and i i
don't know exactly the but it it there
is more generality to this
so for example if f is the indicator
function of some kind of
polytope
it
other questions or works
let's angle around